Hey Steve, ist das das Podcast Info?
Hey Steve, guck mal! Thank you. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge. Macht er seit viereinhalb Minuten, sitzt er so da. Das Podcast-Ufo, das 80s-Ufo. Yeah! Mit mir, Stamitizia und dir, Florentin, Will. Herrlich. Das war ein fantastisches Entro, Hannes. Wir haben wieder heiß mitgetanzt. Wir sind immer ganz außer Atem, wenn die Folge beginnt, weil in den letzten Folgen immer so mit tanzen, mit Gruben. Oh mein Gott. Ich finde ja Sitztanz ohnehin das Beste eigentlich. Mit dem Gesicht, viele Gesten. Ja, viel Gesicht, das Gesicht tanzt in der ersten Reihe, sagt man ja. Erste Stunde Tanzschule heißt es, das Gesicht tanzt vor allem. Es ist auch generell, wenn du ein Glas oder eine Bierflasche in der Hand hast beim Tanzen, müssen ja die anderen Körperteile zwangsläufig ausgleichen, was dieses Körperteil gerade verpasst zu tun. Und dann geht mehr ins Gesicht, auf jeden Fall. Dann wird mal der Mund zusammengeknitten. Und es wird so versucht, die Lyrics mitzusingen, die man ja nicht kennt. Ja, aber es ist auch fast so ein genieserisches, es hat auch was von Essen. Die Lippen werden gespitzt, die Lippen werden spitz. Nee, ich finde das ganz toll, aber Reden während dem Tanzen ist für dich ein Thema, oder bist du voll in der Zone einfach? Schwierig, dann vergesse ich wiederum, dass ich tanze, dann breche ich immer ab. Und wenn eine Pause entsteht, wird wieder getanzt. Das war das Problem, das allererste Mal Paartanz, irgendwie ein Abiball. Man hat dann die Schritte so drin und tanzt halt dann so rum und dann ist so ein, ja, und bei dir so, ist jetzt Abistress oder ist Abistress schon vorbei oder ist ja gerade Corona. Ja, na ja, und Pirouette, Pirouette, Dreh, Dreh, Dreh, Dreh, Dreh, Dreh.
Ich glaube, ich war zu ungeduldig beim Tanzen, auch beim Parttanzen, weil du hast ja dann immer diese, ich nenne es mal Default-Tänze, ne, und dann hast du Tricks.
Nennt man nicht so, ist mir schon auch klar.
Stunts, glaube ich.
Man nennt die nicht Stunts oder Tricks oder Abwechslungen, aber ich wollte dann primär die machen.
Figuren.
Figuren, ne, ja, ja, die wollte ich immer machen und dann war ich immer zu ungeduldig und ich konnte es kaum erwarten, die nächste Figur, die Frau in die nächste Figur zu schmeißen. Und die wusste immer gar nicht, was um sie geschah, wie es um sie geschah, weil ich halt immer nicht dann wieder, weil manerweise macht eine Figur und dann kehrt man wieder zurück zum Tanz. Und dann tanzen, tanzen, tanzen, tanzen, dann schmeißt man wieder eine Figur ein.
Die fand ich aber auch viel spannender und lustiger, da war auch mehr los, man musste auch nicht unangenehm reden, weil man konnte ja nicht reden, weil die Frau sich ja ganz doll um die eigene Achse dreht, wo ich auch sehr froh bin. Ich war nie froher um mein Geschlecht, um ehrlich zu sein, dass ich nicht der Part bin, der sich da so rumdrehen muss. Hm, ne.
Ich komme ursprünglich vom Karate und da ist es halt halt eine andere Situation, und deswegen war bei mir die Partans halt immer so was Kämpferisches. Intuitiv, weil ich bin halt in Kämpfernatur, wenn du halt so diese Martial-Arts-Erfahrung hast, dann kriegst du das halt auch nicht schnell raus. Und deswegen war immer bei mir so, ich wollte immer so gucken, dass das Mädchen nicht checkt, welche Figur ich gerade so, dass ich eine antäusche, aber dann die andere mache. Ja, du hast es mit sich von Tanzen nicht verstanden. Und ich dachte, das Ziel ist es, den Tanzpartner möglichst schlecht aussehen zu lassen. Ah, okay, ja. Wie bei so einem Kampf, wo du den möglichst aus dem Gleichgewicht bringen willst oder irgendwie so umwerfen. Dachte ich auch, dass das Ziel ist. Ist der Tanz das Gegenteil vom Kampf? Ja, was ist Capoeira dann? Das ist die Frage. Das ist die eigentliche Frage, Stefan.
Ja, das ist wie der Fuchs zwischen Hund und Katze. Ich glaube, da weiß man nicht genau, wohin zu werden. Aber ist nicht die Legende bei Capoeira, dass es so eine Art Verstecktes-Kampf, also dass, ich glaube, da war irgendwie so eine Kolonie und da haben dann die Leute gearbeitet, die Gefangenen und dann haben die gesagt, wir wollen. Die durften nicht kämpfen. Genau, die durften nicht kämpfen. Und dann haben die so einen Kampf entwickelt, der aussieht wie ein Tanz. Was aber fehlt in dieser Erzählung ist, haben die dann auch ihre Sklavenhalter tot getanzt? Wie ist das ausgegangen? Ich glaube, dann wurde es primär ein Tanz und dann haben sich eh alle verstanden. Und vielleicht ist das die Lösung. Vielleicht sind die meisten Kriege einfach durch Tänze überwunden. Oder die Sklavenhalter haben gesagt, das ist ja ein toller Tanz, den machen wir jetzt auch und dann sind sie so, verdammt nochmal. Wir kämpfen wir gegeneinander. Aber das ist doch ein genialer Film, das ist so ein bisschen Dirty Dancing meets Pleasantville, irgendwie so, man hat so eine ganz schlechte Gesellschaft, alle müssen in Steinberg, Steinhau, Schlag, Verschlag, Steinbruch oder Bergbau, ich glaube eins, Steinbruch und dann sagt einer, wir müssen jetzt aber kämpfen lernen. Dann sagt er, wir dürfen nicht kämpfen, du weißt, uns untersagt zu kämpfen, wir dürfen weder boxen, noch Karate, noch Taekwondo. Und das war's. Dann sagt er, ja, dann tanzen wir so. Und dann haben die so tanzen und dann machen die so Vorführungen und dann haben die am Ende des Jahres geplant, so für ihre Gefangennehmer so eine grosse Tanzvereinstellung zu machen und dann wirbeln die so rum. Er ist Bobby und nicht Baby, vielleicht der andere Paar. Das ist im Prinzip Dirty Dancing. Ja, und dann tanzen die erst und dann alle so ausgelassen, aber dann kommt der Höhepunkt und dann wirbeln die alle so von der Bühne runter und hauen die ganzen Leute um. Wie so Beyblades. Wie Beyblades. Und dann hauen die alle so um, die können gar nichts gar nichts machen. Was sollen wir dagegen tun? Aber ich habe auch mal Ärger bekommen, weil ich habe einmal diesen Tanz, wo man sich auch bewegt. Ich glaube, ist das Wiener Walzer oder diese andere Walzer? Oder einen Fuchstrott gibt es auch noch. Jedenfalls sind Tänze, wo man sich so im Kreis bewegt, wo man nicht nur darauf achten muss, dass man so weit die Schritte macht, dass man sich dreht, sondern auch durch den Raum bewegt.
Es ist wie so eine,
verschiedene Bezugssysteme, ein bisschen wie so ein planetarisches System.
Also du drehst dich nicht nur Erde und Mond
dreht sich, sondern Erde und Mond dreht sich ja auch noch, obwohl
es sich gleichzeitig dreht, auch noch um die Sonne.
Das heißt, du drehst dich um deine Partnerin,
drehst dich aber auch noch durch den Kreis
in einer grossen Runde und andere
Paare gibt es ja auch noch. Das habe ich immer fehlinterpretiert als Autoscooter primär und fand es eigentlich lustig, meine Partnerin in jemand anderen reinlaufen zu lassen, um dann immer zu sagen, Entschuldigung. Sorry, es hat aber auch was für Bayblade, weil alle drehen sich und es gilt so rauszukägeln aus dem Tanzkreis von der Tanzfläche. Dachte ich auch. Ich dachte, Tanzfläche ist halt so ein abgesetzter Bereich, halt wie so ein Ring. So, und da musst du den anderen rausbringen. Es sieht ja auch so aus mit diesen Spiegelseiten und dieser Stange, die da so ist. Es sieht im Prinzip immer, es hat was von Badewood Arena, kann man nicht abstreiten. Ich habe es interpretiert, habe ich Eiger bekommen. Ich habe mal gearbeitet, in Ferien habe ich gearbeitet für die AWO und dann so Kinder betreut von Leuten, die in Urlaub fahren wollen, die ihre Kinder nicht mit mitnehmen wollen und dann konnte man das machen weil ich habe auch zivil gemacht mit kindern und dann warst du da in diesem haus da wo dann die ganzen kinder eine woche lang sind und dann waren wir diesem großen verhandlungssaal massiv wie eine pokémon pension richtig genau man gibt die kinder und dann holen die eltern die wieder ab und dann ist es entwickelt wie ist es level sechs ich habe es doch mit level elf abgegeben ja das ist nicht leon sondern leon Leonardo, ist die Weiterentwicklung. Genau, ich erkenne dich gar nicht wieder. So ein muskulöser Leonardo. Lass uns fahren, Mutter. Ja. Wer ist unser kleiner Leo? Er entwickelt sich wieder in Leonidas, so ein grosser Bogenschütze jetzt plötzlich. What the fuck? Und da waren wir in dieser grossen Halle und diese Halle war randvoll mit Pokalen. Also wirklich, alle Wände waren mit Regalen versehen, vier reich übereinander und der gesamte Raum war voller Pokale. Du bist in diesen Raum gegangen und dachtest dir, holy crap, hier muss der erfolgreichste Mensch der Welt sein. Da habe ich mir die Pokale mal angeguckt und das war alles Rock'n'Roll-Tanz. Und anscheinend ist da irgendwie so das beste Pärchen der Welt, kommt da irgendwie aus der Nähe von München. Und das war so das Tanzenverein sein, was wir halt verwendet haben für zwei Wochen, um da mit den Kindern irgendwie uns aufzuhalten. Und da dachte ich mir wirklich jeden Tag, die haben so viele Pokale. Soll ich da allen mitnehmen? Ein Pokal-Klauen, verstehst du? Weil Pokal ist so leicht zu klauen. Stell dir vor, wie viel Arbeit die da reingesteckt haben. Und dann musst du den richtigen Partner finden und dann sind sie nervig und dann strengt der Partner sich nicht genug an und dann gibt es Drama und dann sagst du so, ich suche mir einen anderen, aber der hat auch schon eine Partnerin. Das ist alles, das Alter musst du durch, dieser ganze, nicht nur Körper.
Dann kommt Florian Will den Pokal und dann vor seinem Damenbesuch immer zu braggen und dann sagt sie, oh, ich kann auch Rock'n'Roll tanzen, du bist der deutsche Meister und dann beginnt der Film, den ich sehen will, weil dann muss Florian Will nämlich anfangen Rock'n'Roll zu tanzen. Das ist vielleicht der zweite Teil von dem Capoeira-Film.
Von Bobby.
Dann Spinning Bobby Teil zwei, wie sein Sohn den Pokal klaut, um bei den Mädchen zu landen, die aber wiederum, ohne dass er es weiss, Landesmeisterin im Whirling Bobby, Death Bobby, im Death Whirl ist, und dann aber ihn herausfordert, und das ist dann halt Spin-Off halt für Kinder, und Spy-Kids.. Ist ja auch animiert und alle Menschen sind Planes, aber das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Aber ich war neulich, wir haben jetzt ja die zweite Staffel abgedreht und dann gab es ja.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Ja, ja, dann gab es ja Nachvertonungen und so weiter und da wurde ein bisschen Dialog nochmal aufgenommen und dann waren wir in einem Tonstudio und da muss man dann in verschiedenen Tonstudios, das war in Hamburg in einem und da kam es so rein und die ganze Empfangshalle war voller Pokale, also
Ja, das ist ein Problem. Und da muss man dann in verschiedenen Tonstudios. Das war in Hamburg in einem und da kam es so rein und die ganze Empfangshalle war voller Pokale, also Preise für Tonstudios, also für Vertonungen. Bestes Tonstudio. Aber das waren so viele Preise, die, und anscheinend gibt es nicht so viele Tonstudios in Deutschland, dass immer dieses Tonstudio gewinnt. Und die hatten alle Preise aus jedem Jahr und die sahen immer gleich aus. Und dann dachte ich mir, das Erste, was ich gesagt habe, habe mich nicht so ganz sympathisch gemacht, war, stell dir lieber weniger Preise hin, weil so sieht es jetzt aus, als ob er die verkauft. Ja, stimmt. Weil es immer der Gleiche war. So zu mitnehmen an der Rezeption, hast du so eine Schüssel Preise. Ja, genau. Das ist zu viel. Das ist zu viel. Und scheiße, ich wäre super beeindruckt, wenn ihr fünf Preise habt im Regal stehen.
Aber ihr habt, da waren wirklich ungelogen, 70 Preise oder sowas, wo ich dachte, das sieht jetzt wirklich nicht gut aus mehr.
Schmeiss alle raus. Die standen auch so armeemäßig so hintereinander, wie so ein Bataillon.
Schmeiss alle raus bis auf einen und tu das hinter ganz dickes Glas.
Ja, genau.
So eine ganz dicke Vitrine mit so einem Samtkordel,
einmal rumrum und das in die Mitte des Raumes.
Und so eine grosse Kamera, die die raufzeigen.
Ja, genau, und so einen Sicherheitstypen.
Gebt dem bezahlten Sicherheitstypen in Preisen,
gebt dem jeden Tag einen Preis.
Gebt dem 65 Preise.
Ja, damit er den übrigen bewacht.
Das ist viel besser.
Nee, absolut, gebe ich dir völlig recht.
Weil das ist wirklich so, als ob die die Preise verkaufen.
Ab einem gewissen Punkt wird es lächerlich. Und genauso dachte ich mir das auch bei diesem Tanzpokal, wo ich mir dachte, vielleicht gibt es nur ein Paar. Ja, und ich dachte mir so, so schwer können die nicht zu gewinnen sein. So schwer kann Rock'n'Roll nicht sein. Selbst Meryl Streep hat zwei, drei Oscars und es ist einfach die beste. Das heißt, das ist eine Menge schon. Aber auch die stellt bestimmt nicht drei Oscars nebeneinander. Dann denkst du auch schon so, ja, die sind nicht mehr echt. Ja, ja, es stimmt, vielleicht verteilt die die so, dass man erst einsieht und dann durch den Spiegel. The rule of three. Ja, es ist zu viel. Ich glaube, die strengt sich auch gar nicht mehr richtig an, sonst denkt sich, je mehr ich gewinne, desto mehr werden entwertet. Das ist ein Problem. Ich habe aber keinen Pokal geklaut, obwohl ich mir echt, ich habe mir echt tatsächlich geguckt, welcher Pokal, man klaut ja nicht den Punkt kleinsten, sondern also so Danny Ocean-mässig, man geht dann in so eine Bank und guckt sich die Winkel an und so, wo sieht die Kamera und so und so habe ich jeden Tag diesen Raum betrachtet und ich fand es fast cooler, mir immer vorzustellen, was für krasse Heißpläne ich habe und dann ist mein Rucksack groß genug und kann man den Pokal abschauen. So grosse Pokale sind das? Ja, riesige Pokale. Riesige? Riesige Pokale. Oh, die Tonstudio-Preise sind nicht so
gross. Nee, die kann ich mir vorstellen. Das ist
einfach, du hast ja eine Zeremonie, dann so und dann
wirbeln die alle rum und dann so und das ist
total abgefahren. Aber waren das so Standardpokale oder
hatten die schon so eine fancy Form? Das waren
Standardpokale. Ich bin ja auch tatsächlich mal
Trinkpokale. Ich habe ja tatsächlich mal,
ich war ja, man hat ja, wenn man aufwächst,
hat man verschiedene Erweckungsmomente.
So, der Weihnachtsmann existiert nicht. Erwachsene sind gar nicht so klug, so und dann geht es so weiter. Und einen dieser Erweckungsmomente hatte ich, als ich in München durch die Strasse gelaufen bin und dann bin ich vorbeigelaufen an einem Pokalladen, wo man Pokale kaufen kann. Wo ich dachte, Moment, kann ich da jetzt, also muss ich irgendwas vorweisen, um da einen Pokal kaufen zu können? Du kannst dir theoretisch wirklich einfach jeden Pokal drucken lassen. Aber brauche ich, muss ich denn zumindest mal so ein, zwei Rock'n'Roll Schritte vormachen? Oder kann ich einfach sagen, ich hätte gern deutscher Meister im Rock'n'Roll Tanz? Das geht doch nicht. Das ist ja genau wie bei den, ich meine, bei den Golden Globes oder Emmys oder sowas, wo du dann ja auf verbühenden Preis bekommst, aber dann ist es gar kein echter Preis, dann musst du ihn abgeben wieder, dann kriegst du eine Nummer oder eine E-Mail-Rasse, die du anschreiben kannst, wo du dann deinen Namen sagen musst, genau, deinen Namen schreiben musst, und dann musst du, meine ich, als Produktionsführer, wenn du mehr Preise haben willst, die auch noch bezahlen.
Aber musst du da deinen echten Namen eingeben? Ich weiss nicht.
Oder kannst du mit vierten Oscar so Meryl Sheep
also als Spaß.
Meryl Sheep.
Ja, oder einfach irgendwas anderes angeben.
Die Leute, come on,
Mrs. Sheep, that's ...
Wird Meryl Sheep angerufen.
Mäh!
Ja, aber kann noch sagen. Mach mal eine Ziege nach kurz. Mäh! Mach mal ein Schaf nach. Mäh! Ja? Ja, ich glaube, Ziegen haben eher so Schreiende. Sind Ziegen nicht nackte Schafe? Mäh, mäh, ja eher so mäh. Ich habe jetzt Tiger King geschaut, die Doku, und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass junge Tiger gar nicht brüllen, sondern einfach schreien. Die reissen einfach so ganz doll ihren Mund auf und die Augen und machen einfach nur wie so genervte Kinder. Wie eine Ziege im Grunde, ja. Ja, oder so nervige Kinder. Ja. Oh, sehr zu empfehlende Doku. Schaut es euch an. Unbedingt anschauen. Es gibt viele Dokus gerade, die man gucken kann. Man guckt ja auch gerade viel bei der Zeit.
Ich gucke tatsächlich weniger irgendwie. Ich bin überflutet so ein bisschen, aber ich kriege es nicht hin. Aber wie gesagt, ich versuche weiterhin Französisch zu lernen. Mir ist das aber aufgefallen, weil ich glaube, weil so, ich habe jetzt auch so ein Grammatiklernbuch, wo man dann so Lückentexte ausfllen muss. Und diese Lückentexte sind ja toll, weil eigentlich müssen die ja ganz neutral sein. Weil es geht ja nur darum, die Sprache zu lernen. Aber manche erzählen dann trotzdem so eine Geschichte oder manchmal ist so ein Witzchen hier und da. Das ist dann doch die furchtbare Autobiografie des Französischlehrers. Und mir ist mittlerweile aufgefallen, ich bin jetzt bei der dritten Zeitform, und mir ist aufgefallen, bei jedem zweiten Lückentext geht es um Einbruch.
Aber das hatten wir doch schon mal.
Es ist immer so. Duolingo ist halt abgefahren sick, also sick, wirklich, wo es immer darum geht, Oma bringt Opa um uns, also grauenvolle Beispieltexte, wo man sich immer fragt, wo kommt das denn jetzt her? Und es ist ein bisschen Stil, oder? Ist es Stilmittel von Duolingo? Ich glaube, also ich meine, sowas muss ja jemand schreiben. Es gibt ja Autoren und dann kann ja sein, dass da irgendwie Traumata verarbeitet werden, weil es heißt dann wirklich so, oh nein, bei uns wurde eingebrochen, der Dieb hat gestohlen, den Kühlschrank, den Herd, den Taschenrechner und dann wird aufgezählt. Die Frau wurde vergewaltigt. Und dann, jetzt lernen wir Adverbien.
Die Stiebe brachen leise ein.
Der Dieb benutzt gekletterte vorsichtig aufs Dach.
Er schaltete die Alarmanlage technisch aus.
Die Polizei wurde zu spät gerufen. Ja, Die Nachbarin erlitt einen schweren Herz. Dann denkst du immer so, was ist denn falsch bei euch, Leute? Gut, dass Pierre nicht im Haus war, denn sie hatten eine geladene Waffe dabei. What? Jedes Mal. Man will anrufen und sagen, geht seinem Autoren gut. Ja, kann man da mal so präventiv Streifenwagen hinschicken. Aber vielleicht ist es so, ja, vielleicht war der Dieb und hat dann gesagt, nee, das mache ich nicht mehr. Aber lernst du das auf Deutsch, Französisch oder lernst du auf Englisch Französisch? Nee, Deutsch. Weil ich habe auf Englisch Japanisch gelernt, was auf allen Ebenen nicht funktionieren kann, glaube ich. Weil ich bin ja ein anderer Mensch, wenn ich auf Englisch spreche und denke. Du bist besser, du bist cooler, coolerer Typ. Ich bin ein cooler Typ, klar, bin aber auch ein dümmerer Typ, weil ich nicht so viele Vokabeln beherrsche und ich automatisch anfange, auf Englisch zu denken und so und es natürlich nicht gute Gedanken sein können, weil wie auch. Ist auch eine interessante Sprache, wie oft muss man eine Sprache sprechen oder wie regelmäßig, um dann auch so zu denken, wenn man auf der Sprache spricht. Finde ich spannend. Jedenfalls hat dann dieser coole dumme Typ angefangen, Japanisch zu lernen. Und mein deutsches Ich war die ganze Zeit außen vor, hat irgendwo Animal Crossing gespielt. So und das war distanziert und ich weiß nicht. Also der deutsch sprechende Stefan gerade kann kein Wort Japanisch. Du bist so der dritte bei einem Date. Die verstehen sich super und du stehst so dabei. Die sprechen auch beide ihre Sprachen und so und haben Freundinnen und so. Die haben eine gute Zeit. Ja, und du einfach daneben. Keine Ahnung davon. Ja. Das ist interessant. Aber ich habe wirklich überlegt, wenn du in der dritten Zeitform bist, dann kannst du ja schon mittlerweile sehr gut von Südde sprechen wahrscheinlich. Naja, dritte Zeitform ist nicht so viel, da gibt es total
crazy viele. Haben die auch Foto 2
und Pluscom Perfekt? Ja, da gibt es alles.
Ja? Und dann haben die noch so ganz
weirde Sachen, die es im Deutschen gar nicht gibt, die man
noch speziell lernen muss. Es ist mega strange,
aber ich habe mir echt überlegt, ob ich irgendwie
ein großes Projekt angehen soll, weil
ich würde gerne die
perfekte
Karteikarten-App programmieren. Zum Sprache lernen. Ja. Weil ich habe gerne die perfekte Karteikarten-App programmieren zum Sprachelernen.
Ja.
Weil ich habe viele Ideen, was man bei Vokabellern-Apps verbessern könnte.
Aber mir fehlen natürlich die technischen Möglichkeiten, das zu programmieren.
Weil ich mir echt überlege, soll ich jetzt irgendwie anfangen, JavaScript oder sowas zu lernen?
Natürlich die klassische Szene, 22.30 Uhr, man denkt, jetzt fange ich nochmal von vorne an, schaut sich ein Tutorial, denkt sich no fucking way und schaut und klickt sich wieder weiter durch Netflix, ohne was anzuschauen und dann geht man dann ins Bett. So, das ist der klassische Abend, aber es gibt so viele Möglichkeiten, weil ich finde die Vokabellern-Apps sind so schlecht. Allein zum Beispiel die Tatsache, nur eine Idee, ich habe vier Ideen, genau vier, aber die drei sage ich dir nicht, weil die drei sind zu gut. Eine Idee zum Beispiel, du lernst jetzt ein neues Wort, sagen wir mal schlafen. So, dann benutzt du das Wort schlafen ja in der Regel nicht im Infinitiv, sondern du sagst, er schläft, wir schlafen und so weiter. Das heißt, idealerweise würdest du die Vokabel schlafen in deinen Karteikartenstapel eingeben und dann, wenn der dich die Vokabeln abfrägt, fragt der aber nie den Infinitiv ab, sondern immer schon eine konjugierte Form, sondern du schläfst und dann musst du einfach eingehen, welches Wort wollen sie haben, S-C-H-L-A, schlafen oder vorgeschlagen, zack und dann fragt der einen von sieben ab, die sechs Zeitformen oder Infinitiv und fragt dich die immer ab und immer wenn du dieses Wort neu treffen würdest in einem Karteikartenstapel, wird zufällig eins von denen ausgewählt, sodass du das immer so lernst, weil es passiert total oft, du kannst den Infinitiv, liest aber einen französischen Text und siehst das Wort da als Ich-Form und erkennst es überhaupt nicht, weil du immer nur die Infinitiv-Form hast. Du kannst ja vielleicht auch am Anfang im Menü auswählen, wie krass du gerade lernen willst. Ja, und dann hast du diese sieben Punkte und kannst dann so Häkchen machen, wie ich will doch nur den Infinitiv lernen oder ich will nur du und ihr oder so, weil die besonders schwierig sind. Kannst du Zeitformen anklicken, die du schon kennst. Genau, ja, Zeitformen dann imperfekt dazu und zack und dann wird das alles immer durchrotiert. Genial! Wie funktionieren denn generell diese Karteikarten-Apps? Gibst du die Wörter ein, die du lernst? Gibt's, ja, also ich mag am liebsten die, wo man die selber eintippt. Ich mag das nicht, wenn du so Wortpacken hast, weil die sind alle Crap. Und vor allem das Dumme ist, ich weiß nicht, wer immer diese Reihenfolge festlegt, in welcher Reihenfolge man Vokabeln lernt. Ich finde generell, eine Sprache, eine Sprachlern-App zu programmieren, holy fuck, ist superschwer. Weil, wo fängt man da an? Da würde ich schon aufgeben, auch Mathematik beizubringen. Ja, es ist eigentlich immer, best was im Restaurant, ist immer Lektion eins. Und das heißt, deine ersten Vokabeln sind Bier, Tee, Kaffee, Milch, Wein. Und denkst du dir, das interessiert mich alles überhaupt nicht. Ich lerne jetzt 20 Getränke, bevor ich weiß, was irgendwie Laufen heißt oder so. Und dann ist es total nervig. Deswegen mache ich immer die selber. Und dann, ich habe noch eine zweite Idee raus. Man soll sich ja beim Lernen Ziele setzen. So, zum Beispiel, ich habe hier diesen Film, den würde ich gern schauen in der Originalsprache. Also lerne ich diese Sprache. Und jetzt kannst du in meiner Karteikarten-App den Film auswählen, und der checkt den gesamten Text des Films und gibt dir alle Vokabeln, die du noch nicht kannst, dieses Films in eigenen Stapel, so dass du die Vokabeln speziell für diesen Film lernen kannst und dann, wenn du die kannst, schaust du den Film und du verstehst die das Wort. Ja, super speziell. Genial! Aber jeder hätte Bock, so zu lernen. Jeder hätte Bock, so zu lernen. Wenn du Japanisch lernst und du sagst, du willst jetzt Prinzessin Mononoke im Original sehen, dann kannst du, das sind dann halt eine Menge wahrscheinlich, eine Menge Vokabeln, aber kannst du genau die lernen.
Alle Wörter, einmal.
Oder eine Serie und dann sagt er dir, die erste Folge hat folgende 200 Wörter, die du noch nicht kennst, weil dein Vokabellern weiss ja, welche Wörter du schon kannst.
Das müsste vor allem sehr einfach gehen, weil diese ganzen Texte ja, diese ganzen Subteile sind ja gespeichert immer.
Alle drin.
Die sind ja alle da. Es gibt vielleicht. Oder in der Zahl Pi. Ja. Okay. Wir wissen, auf welchem YouTube-Deep da du momentan so unterwegs bist. Aber mir wurde übrigens empfohlen, es gibt Plugins für Netflix, dass man die übersetzten Untertitel sich anzeigen lassen kann. Also auf, sagen wir mal, japanisch. Aber als Lippentexte. Das wäre immer geil. Auf japanisch und dann nochmal auf deutsch. Also du kannst dich auf japanisch lehnen, wenn du nicht checkst und er kann auch anhalten nach jedem Satz. Das war unsere Premiere in Cannes ungefähr, wo drei Texte drunter standen, drei Texte und dann noch die Screens der Jugendlichen übersetzt wurden, weshalb der ganze Film war voller Text und das ganze Theater in Cannes hat, glaube ich, noch nie so viel gelesen müssen. Das war ganz unangenehm. Vor allem du liest dann alle drei Sprachen bei jedem Satz. Du liest natürlich auch, ich habe auch was durchgelesen. Weil ich dachte, ach so übersetzen die das? Kein Wort gesprochen. Finde ich spannend, das finde ich gut. Ich finde aber auch gut, dass du erst Vokabeln hinzufügen kannst wieder, wenn du gewisse Durchgänge abgeschlossen hast. So zwingst du dich zum mehr Lernen. Das heißt, du musst sie zumindest alle einmal nochmal durchgespielt haben, um neue hinzuzufügen. Also sagen wir mal, du kannst, du musst irgendwie dreimal eine Karte gespielt haben und weggeklickt haben, um neue hinzuzufügen. Das finde ich auch spannend. Da gibt es so viele Möglichkeiten. Oder kaufen. Alternativ In-App-Kauf. In-App-Kauf. Ja, die ganzen, die besten Wörter, die längsten Wörter kosten was. Ab acht Buchstaben ist es kostenpflichtig. Ja, kostenpflichtig. So eine Will-to-pay-wall, was dazu führt, dass Leute einfach sehr kurze Wörter sprechen die Sprache sehr gut, aber halt sehr kurz. Aber sehr schnell. Ja, so einsilbige Wörter. Genau, so das beste Wort. Das beste Wort kostet 100 Euro. Was ist das beste Wort? Wenn du das freischalten willst, dann kostet es 100, ja eben, jetzt bist du bereit, 100 Euro zu zahlen. Halbseiden. Halbseiden, lauwarm. Das ist das beste Wort, lauwarm. Da kann man es umtauschen, aber wenn man nicht zufrieden ist. Ja, finde ich gut. Da ist noch so viel drin. Komm, haut Tipp drei raus. Nee, nee, mache ich nicht. Okay, wirklich? Ich habe wirklich Angst, dass mir Leute das klauen, weil ich finde, das ist eine lukrative Idee, weil und natürlich, klar, die Leute sagen jetzt, oh mein Gott, warum denkst du nicht an Audio? Ich habe an Audio gedacht, Leute, macht euch das. Ist einer der Tipps Audio? Nee, ja, so weit will ich nicht gehen, aber natürlich habe ich auch an Audio gedacht, ist ja logisch. Ist klar. Ich bin gespannt, was da auf dem Markt nämlich los ist, auf dem Karteikarten-App-Markt. Ja, und ich schaue gerade Chef's Table die französische Edition, weil anscheinend gibt es da noch mal extra Editionen von verschiedenen Ländern, wo die auch alle französisch sprechen. Ja, wobei ich glaube nur Französisch, glaube ich. Ja, kann sein, weiß ich nicht. Kann sein, aber das ist natürlich echt schwer, weil die halt ständig dann irgendwie Zutaten aufzählen und du halt dann Ente, Karotte, Schaluppe, Safran und du hast halt keine Ahnung, du schenkst nichts. Ist zumindest lustig, weil Köche häufig die erste Silbe betonen eines Wortes. Wirklich? Ja, und irgendwie hat sich das durchgesetzt. Restaurant. Ja. Pommes. Von allen Wörtern. Backofen. Pfanne. Gabel. Pfanne. Nee, sie sagen Pfanne, nicht Pfanne. Pfanne. Ja, guck mal, Theorie widerlegt. Nee, mir fällt auch gar nicht die wilden Kartoffel. Ja. Aber es ist wirklich auch falsch betont teilweise, sich über die deutsche Sprache hinwegsetzen und die erste Silbe betonen. Ja? Habe ich schon häufig gehört, ja genau wie Schweizer. Schweizer machen das und Köche. Das hat sich nämlich so durchgesetzt, die betonten. Ist das so ein Berufsethos oder was, dass man so sagt, man hat eine eigene Sprache? Vielleicht. Ein Geheimzeichen? Wo Sprache in Küchen ja auch relativ wichtig ist und sich so eigene Kosmen da hinter den Türen, hinter den Klapptüren. Wie auch immer man die nennt. Ist das ein Roman, Hinter der Klapptür? Hinter der Klapptür. Auf der anderen Seite dieser klappernden Tür, dieser, die so in dieses Schloss fällt. Ihr wisst schon. Hat jeder schon mal gesehen mit dem Lochfenster. Was in Deutschlands Küchen wirklich passiert von Stefan Tietze.
So ein Enthüllungsroman, der aber nach der Hälfte ins Fiktive abdriftet, weil dir der Stoff ausgekratzt.
Und dann doch eine weirde Kurzgeschichte abdriftet, die zu Recht abgelehnt wurde.
Also du dachtest, der Lektor liest nicht so weit.
Ja, und ich meine jetzt einfach der E-Mail-Streib dem Lektor. Das wird es wahrscheinlich dann noch werden. Werbung. Einer, hast du dich noch an deine erste Rasur, Florin? Oh Gott, viel zu spät, viel zu stumpf, viel zu schmerzhaft. Ich war so ein Pflaumenjunge und dann mit viel Schmerz. Ja, ich auch bei mir und vor allem habe ich so wahnsinnig sensible Haut, weshalb ich immer so Rasierpickelchen bekomme, bis ich Gillette entdeckt habe, meine sensible Haut ist jetzt kein Problem mehr für mich, denn die Skin Guard Sensitive Technologie wurde speziell dafür entwickelt. Und jetzt gibt es ganz neu den Skin Guard Sensitive Flexball und den Gillette Mach 3 Turbo 3D. Also die beiden Klassiker, die wir von Gillette schon kennen, wurden weiterentwickelt mit einer Flexball-Technologie,
sodass du halt wirklich, weil es flexibel ist und es drehbar ist, in jede Ecke, der ins Gesicht kommt, selbst wenn du so eine krasse Jawline hast wie ich.
Ja, ja, und ich habe ein sehr eckenreiches Gesicht, von daher passt das. Die Klingen sind made in Berlin und trotzdem bezahlbar, denn mit dem Promocode PUFO20 kriegt ihr das Ganze jetzt 20% billiger, ihr kriegt den SkinGuard Flexball 20% günstiger.
Wenn das nicht was ist. Promo-Code PUFO20 kriegt ihr das Ganze jetzt 20% billiger, ihr kriegt den Skinguard Flexball 20% günstiger.
Wenn das nicht was ist, also rasiert eure Gesichter.
Werbung.
Apropos E-Mails.
Ja.
Letzte Woche konnte ich den grossen Erfolg verbuchen, worstbird.com. Worstbird.com wurde gekauft für 50 Dollar. 50 Dollar. Und keinen Cent mehr. Keinen einzigen Cent mehr, wir haben darüber gesprochen. Und ja, die Community war in heller Aufregung, weil sie natürlich gesagt hat, okay, jetzt das Quartett voll machen. Du kannst nicht nur Worstbird besitzen, so dust dann halt auch Best Bird. Average Bird, Okay Bird, Medium Bird, brauchst du alles. Und deswegen habe ich mich diese Woche an bestbird.com gemacht. Aber unsere Produktionsfirma, das ist wichtig für mich und den Bürokratieaufwand, die Bürokratieflut, Formularflut, die auch uns zukommt, wir bleiben bei Worst Bird. Unsere Firma bleibt weiterhin bei Worst Bird, aber ich dachte natürlich, ich hole mir noch Best Bird, weil ich war im Kaufrausch. Ja, verstehst. Ich war drin und ich war im Verhandlungsrausch. Meine Frage jetzt und auch die von, wie heisst er noch immer, Raquel, warum hast du jetzt plötzlich wieder 50 Dollar? Raymond, Raymond. Raymond meinst du? Ja. Woher kommen die jetzt? Da musste ich mir natürlich eine Geschichte überlegen. Aber nein, tatsächlich war bestbird.com in der Hand von einer anderen Domain Broker Agency. Das heißt, ich konnte meine Karten perfekt ausspielen und den alten 50-Dollar-Trick, der mittlerweile sehr erfolgreich auch auf Ebay-Kleinanzeigen angewendet wird. Mir hat jemand einen Chatverlauf geschickt, wie er diese 50-Dollar-Taktik verwendet hat, um sich was zu kaufen. Toll, also an alle da draußen, die 50-Dollar-Taktik einfach immer beharrern, man hätte nur 50 Euro und kann nicht mehr ausgeben. Und jetzt würde ich gerne ein Gewinnspiel ausrufen. Wir machen das jetzt von jetzt an drei Wochen lang jedes Gewinnspiel. Ihr schickt uns eure Chatverläufe, in denen ihr handelt, wo ihr jeweils sagt, I only have 50 Dollars, ich habe nur 50 Euro, und derjenige, der das teuerste von euch erhandelt, sich erhandelt, kriegt von uns 50 Euro. Du meinst, der von dem höchsten Preis runterhandelt. Genau, der, der den teuersten Gegenstand von euch sich erhandelt, mit der ich habe nur 50 Euro Taktik, kriegt von mir 50 Euro obendrauf. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Fakes können wir riechen, also versucht es erst gar nicht. Und Bonuspunkte natürlich für ein Bild von eurer Brieftasche, in dem ein trauriger 50 Euro Schein drin ist. und er sagt, mehr habe ich nicht. Ich habe dir den Chatverlauf geschickt zu Best Bird. Jetzt gerade? Dann kannst du ja vielleicht nachvollziehen, als kleines Lehrbeispiel, als kleines Anschauungsbeispiel, wie das laufen könnte. Denn bei bestbird.com konnte man direkt nämlich ein Price-Offer abgeben, wenn man auf der Seite war, bestbird.com. Und ich habe natürlich als Price-Offer 50 Dollar, aber das steht nicht mehr noch nicht, ich habe direkt 50 Dollar angegeben und dann dachte ich, okay, was passiert jetzt? Ich tipp da halt ein, 50 Dollar und man wurde sofort weitergeleitet in einem Chat. Man war sofort in einem Chat, wo ich gesagt habe, Proposes 50 Dollar und ich musste sofort loschatten. Ich war sofort im Chat. Und Mohammed Khan hat geantwortet sofort. Und jetzt kannst du dir das erste ist ein Screenshot von dem Chatverlauf, was ich dann geschrieben habe. Okay. Aber den kann ich nicht sehen, weil es ein SIP-Datei ist. Du hast geschrieben, dies ist kein Live-Chat. Nee, hat er geschrieben, Mohammed Khan, Domain Broker. Dies ist kein Live-Chat. Ich werde mich in Kürzester bei ihm melden. Du hast geschrieben, am Looking for Website, I only got 50 Dollars. Ich kann es nicht sehen, weil der Screenshot abgeschnitten ist. Wieso ist der abgeschnitten? Ja, das ist halt so nett. Ah ja, ja, ja. Made an offer of 50 Dollars. Genau, das war automatisiert. Hey Mohammed, do you speak German? I am looking for a website from a local band to post big gig dates and stuff. I only have fifty dollars. Okay, mir fällt auch deine colloquial Sprache, weil die haben es versucht, auf so eine Business, bei uns geht es um grosse Summen, auf so einen Sprech zu heben. Du hast mit dem Duktus direkt klargemacht, hier geht es nicht um die Zehntausender, hier geht es um fifty dollars. Immer den Verhandlungspartner auf seinem Niveau herunterzerken. Ja, deswegen auch I'm looking for a website for my local banner, post gigdates and stuff. And stuff, ja, genau. Der sagt direkt, der sagt direkt, ich hab kein Geld, Leute. Er hat geschrieben, hello Florentin, my name is Mohammed Khan, ein Name ist Domain Broker, das represents the The owner of bestbird.com. I spoke to my client, nope. Erstens bestbird.com, der Name Domain Broker that represents theowner of bestbird.com. I spoke to my client, nope. Erstens, bestbird.com, der Owner, hat doch keinen, der hat sich auch keine Agency geholt. Das ist doch alles eine Lüge, I am Domain Broker that represents theowner of bestbird.com. Vor allem, ich stelle mir den Owner von Best World vor, wie er in so einer riesigen Villa auf so einem Whirlpool liegt und etwas sagt.
What, excuse me.
Ist ein Storch.
What, what do you do? How do you get so much money? You have ever heard of the website bestbird.com? Dann geht man in so einen weirden Flashback, wo er einfach nur einen Mausklick macht und dann ist er direkt da. Das langweilige Flashback der Welt. I spoke to my client regarding this and their expectations are 19.000 US 19 000 us dollars what the fuck best bird dot com ist viel teurer als worst bird dot com war sportbillig selbst die ganz ursprünglichen 2350 dollar von worst bird sind nichts im vergleich das obwohl sich worst Dass Burt sogar reimt, ist ja sogar ein intrinsischer Reim. 19.000 Dollar. Und vor allem, das schreibt er auf meinen Price Offer von 50 Dollar, antwortet er. Ja, und your band and stuff. Please call me. Eine sehr lange Nummer, muss man sagen. If you would like to discuss the rationale behind this evaluation and next steps, how does your schedule look in the next couple of days? Ja, offensichtlich hast du keinen Schedule. Aber erst mal da dachte ich mir, ich habe ihn am Haken. Weil, wenn ich 50 Dollar offere und er sagt 19.000, dann sagt er nicht, lass uns mal schnell telefonieren in den nächsten Tagen. Weil, der wirklich mit 19.000 rechnet, dann sagt er einfach, das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Deswegen dachte ich mir, okay, ich habe ihn am Haken. Jetzt muss ich weiter auf die emotionale Schiene gehen und ihm klar machen, dass ich nur 50 Dollar habe. Er hat sich verraten, vor allem, ja, wir alle kennen deine Taktik, er hat sich aber vor allem sich verraten mit In The Next Couple of Days, finde ich auch. Absolut. Also mit diesem Titan Schedule. Ja. Du hast geschrieben, hey, Mohammed, oh, mir gefällt nicht, dass du jetzt deine Bands and Stuff und make my music and so. Wieso, hey, hey ist colloquial.
Ja, aber jetzt fängst du an, auch mit Greetings und so,
plötzlich wird das Ganze ein bisschen professioneller.
Na, guck mal rein.
Thanks for your mail and price offer.
Nineteen thousand dollars is a bit much for me,
as I can only spend fifty dollars.
I'm part of a local band,
and we would like to use the site to post gig dates and stuff.
Mir gefällt die Redundanz.
Well, I'm not really part of the band as such.
I take care of PR and communications and such stuff.
You could say manager, but the rest of the boys and one girl don't like my saying I't like my saying i'm the manager so you decide greetings florentin ja mir gefällt diese private schiene dieses du beziehst ihn ein in ein privates problem absolut absolut wir sind eine band ich bin so ein bisschen der der der communications typ 50 dollar knallhart ihm. Er lässt das Hey weg, Florentin.
We will need to be in the thousands of dollars for me to take it to the owner.
Oh, man merkt, der Owner von bestbird.com, der spricht nicht mit jedem.
Und der wurde schon mal angesprochen auf etwas, was nicht in den Tausendern war.
Und da hat Mohammed Khan schon mal eine Abfuhr bekommen. Please contact me. If things change dramatically, I don't think we will need the website to post our fucking gig dates and stuff. Wow. Ich liebe diese Formulierung, if things change dramatically. Dramatically on your end. Das ist ein notwendiger Wechsel von 50 auf 19.000, das ist dramatically. Ja, das ist dramatisch. Und wenn Dinge on your end nicht dramatisch sich ändern, dann müssen wir hier gar nicht... Aber was glaubt er, dass du immer noch interessiert bist daran? Holy shit, grossartig. Aber ja, er ist hart, er ist hart, er ist vielleicht mein härtester Gegner bis jetzt, aber ich werde auf jeden Fall dranbleiben. Mal gucken, ob ich ihn erst auf tausend bringen kann und dann vielleicht mal mit dem Owner rede und dann gucken, was der Owner, ob der Owner nicht vielleicht sagt, okay, 50 Dollar ist okay, aber er ist hart. Ich mache häufig die Erfahrung, dass Leute dumm sind. Ja? Ja, weil Leute lieber gar nichts nehmen als 50 Dollar. Ja. Wenn Sie nämlich so hohe Erwartungen haben, nehmen sie lieber nichts als etwas. Das kennt man häufig auch so bei Gehaltsverhandlungen. Sie nehmen den Job lieber nicht als für zu wenig. Also sie geben ja ihre Zeit, ja. Ja, die geben lieber, sie geben ihren Stolz nicht gerne ab, aber sie nehmen wie lieber nichts als etwas. Ja, vielleicht muss ich noch mal mit ihm telefonieren, ich hab seine Nummer, aber ich fand's auch schon komisch, als er gesagt hat, call me in the next days. Ich glaube, da ist was machbar. Ich glaub auch, ehrlich gesagt, ich halte diese Strategie immer noch für strodof und blöde und nicht nachvollziehbar und hat zweifellos quasi Glückstreffer erzielt, aber ich halte sie immer noch für bescheuert. Dennoch glaube ich, dass sie im Broker, Domain Broker Business gar nicht so schlecht ist. Ich glaube vor allem da geht es primär um überhaupt irgendeine Nachfrage. Du kannst ja als Domain Broker auch nicht so tun, als wäre das was wert. Also angenommen, du hast jetzt eine teure Vase und du verkaufst sie für viel mehr zu verkaufen, als sie wert ist, dann kannst du sagen, ja, die ist alt, die ist schön verarbeitet, das ist ein Unikat und so, da kannst du irgendwie noch so ein Handelsgespräch führen. Bei der Webseite ist jedem klar, die hat keinen Wert, also nichts, da kannst du einfach nur sagen, ja, Best Bird, halt. Das ist halt zwei Wörter zusammen. Das ist so offensichtlich.
Ich spreche mal mit dem Besitzer, weil dem liegt ja auch was an der Website, Ebene gehoben, wie man sagt, was macht der Besitzer mit bestbird.com? Vor allem auf bestbird.com, sag mal, liegt viel mehr Potential als nichts.
Ja, vor allem kann ich mit meiner Webseite hollobollo.de. Auf bestbird.com, sag mal, liegt viel mehr Potenzial als nichts.
Ja, vor allem kann ich mit meiner Webseite, hollo-bollo.de, zu diesem Broker gehen und sagen, hey, verscherbe die mal für viel Geld.
Also welche Kriterien hat wiederum der Broker, welche Webdomains er denn annimmt? Der muss ja auch irgendeine Evolution sagen. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ich habe stefan-tietze.de, hau da mal richtig viel Geld für raus, übernimmt Mohammed das, oder was? Das ist eine gute Frage. Was ist mit StephenTiles.com? Aber ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Angst, dass Leute jetzt mehr bieten, als wir für Best Bird.mehr als 19.000 Dollar. Hast du mal unsere Hörer gesehen? Mehr als 50 Dollar, wir bieten ja nur 50 Dollar. Nein, machen die nicht. Die sind auf unserer Seite, die wollen, nee, nee, nee, die wollen das für bestbird. Ich bin ja schon mal froh, dass wir bestbird.com haben. Ich bin auch heilfroh und es haben auch Leute geschrieben, ja, Leute, euch ist schon klar, wenn ihr jetzt bestbird bekommt, dann müsst ihr halt auch wesentlich bessere Vögel liefern als bisher. Und das stimmt. Und ich weiß nicht, ob wir dem nachkommen können. Ja, vielleicht ist es auch eine Bürde, die wir uns nicht auferlegen wollen. Vielleicht ist Worst Bird auch erstmal für uns dann auch erstmal genug. Vielleicht ist es okay, okay Birds könnte man noch gucken, ob das funktioniert. Aber ich glaube, dann reicht es auch irgendwann.
Aber ja, es ist auf jeden Fall die Frage, was wir dann halt machen damit.
Auf jeden Fall.
Jedenfalls ist das Podcast so für jetzt offiziell eine Worst Bird Production.
It's a Worst Bird Production.
Und wir freuen uns auf sehr viele weitere Worst Bird Productions, ehrlich gesagt.
Ganz offen, viel mehr wird nicht passieren.
Die Pipeline ist gerade trocken.
Worst Bird ist gerade auch ausgelastet. Also die Mitarbeiter arbeiten alle auf heissen Kohlen.
Ja. wie alle anderen. Also bei uns sind gerade die Hütten voll und die Schotten dicht und man muss halt gucken, wie es weitergeht. Wo man bleibt. Ja, oder so. Wie mein Kollege gerade gesagt hat. Ja, aber ansonsten ist jetzt erstmal, wir haben versucht, einen Pitch für unsere Worst Bird Show zu pitchen, aber da sind wir auch noch nicht weitergekommen. Nee, wir sind noch nicht weitergekommen. Aber ansonsten. Wir haben versucht erstmal so eine Firmenzentrale zu finden, aber auch da. Das ist schwierig momentan. Viele gehen nicht ran. Gerade. Gibt es irgendeine Firma, die wirklich null Euro verdient hat? Ja. Ich glaube, es gibt viele Firmen, die weniger als null Euro verdient haben. Naja, aber ich meine jetzt nicht Umsatz meine ich, nicht verdienen, sondern Umsatz, die wirklich gesagt haben, okay, wir machen jetzt Pfannen, aber so Doppeldeckerpfannen, dass du zwei Sachen gleichzeitig braten kannst auf nur einer Herdplatte und dann werden da tausend produziert und von den tausend, die produziert werden, werden exakt null verkauft. Ja. Null, also nicht mal so eine, sondern wirklich null und man sagt, so. Ich glaube, weil es ist ein unwritten Gesetz, das zumindest die Mutter. Ist es? Ich glaube nämlich auch, dass es so BWL so im zweiten Semester sagt, okay, ihr habt die Basics drauf, jetzt kommen wir mal zu den wichtigen. The Mother Law. The Mother Law. The Mother Law. Ja. The Dad Law ist übrigens, dass man immer einen Verbesserungsvorschlag bekommt, den man dringend nicht umsetzen sollte, sonst tritt das Mother-Law ein, das nur die Mutterkau.
You can always count on the Mother-Law. You will always sell one item. You will at least sell one item to your mother. Und da ist es, ah, wow, zwei Pfaden gleichzeitig ist ja praktisch, aber gibt es wirklich Produkte, die kein einziges, oder es gibt ja Quoten, so Quoten von Fernsehsendungen. Gibt es Shows, das ist generell eine Frage, Dinge, die passiert sind. Ist schon mal XYZ passiert? Hat schon mal jemand, niemand eine Show geguckt im Fernsehen? Ja, das ist wirklich am Ende das Quote Null. Aber ich falle, was ist der grösste Sender, bei dem eine Show schon mal von Null Leuten geguckt wurde? So wurde schon mal eine RTL-Sendung von exakten null Menschen geguckt. Und du hast die Quoten und denkst dir, das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Das gibt es doch gar nicht. Nicht mal du, du hast die Sendung gemacht. Ja, nee, ich hatte halt keine Zeit. Null. Nicht mal deine Mutter hat sie geschaut. Niemand. Ja. Aber das frage ich mich eh, weil es muss ja, es muss es ja schon mal passiert sein. Auf jeden Fall. Auf jeden Fall. Aber bei Quoten ist es auch immer so eine Sache, weil die sind ja nicht so richtig genau. Bei Quoten denke ich mir immer, gerade bei so ZDF Neo, bei den Quoten, die es bei uns ja auch um Leben und Tod ging, beim Neo Magazin. Die 0,8 Prozent, ja. Die 0,8 Prozent. Da reicht ja, wenn einer mit so einer Box das guckt, dass man das verdoppelt. Also wir hätten ja nur einen Menschen finden müssen, und die Chance ist ja nicht klein, mit so einer Box, der das dann immer guckt. Das ist doch Wahnsinn, das ist das bestgehütete Geheimnis der Welt. Ich glaube nicht. Ich meine, selbst irgendwelche Regierungsskandale kommen raus, aber dieses Wer hat so eine Box ist so geheim, kann sich da nicht mehr mal reinhacken. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass die deutsche Medienagentur, was auch immer, so krass ist, dass man das nicht hacken kann. Und dann schauen alle irgendwie Balou und dann sagen die Öffentlich-Rechtigen, jetzt machen wir halt nur noch Balou. Ja, nur weil die ja auch ein bisschen Spaß erlaubt haben, weil die drei in der GfK-Box und WhatsApp-Gruppe sich zusammen telefoniert haben und die sagten, nee, wir gucken jetzt mal schön, Caillou. Ja, oder Caillou. 50 Prozent Balou und 50 Prozent Caillou, das sind die Quoten. Ich muss das nochmal checken lassen, aber es stimmt. Du willst mir sagen, dass jeder, der nicht Balou geschaut hat, hat Kaju geschaut. Komischer Tag. So zehn hochernste Menschen, das kann doch nicht was sein. Warum gucken Leute entweder Killou oder Balou? Aber Leute, wenn ihr so eine Box habt, dann kümmert euch mal wieder, wer die noch hat, weil er bricht nicht viel in der Hand. Und die werden hier auf die Goldwaage gelegt, diese Quoten, was ja auch immer so Quatsch ist. Ich verstehe es auch immer nicht, warum. Ja, irgendwas muss man ja auf die Goldwaage legen. Ja? Lass doch mal die Goldwaage in Ruhe. Ja, aber wenn du die schon hast. Stimmt, da muss ich auch benutzt werden. Da muss ich auch was drauflegen. Ja, das stimmt schon. Mindestens einmal in der Woche muss man was nehmen. Wenn man sowas Teures hat, dann muss man das auch benutzen. Ja. Aber es gibt ja die durchschnittlichste Stadt Deutschlands, Hassloch, wo ich ja immer gerne eine Kommunistische-Riode machen wollte. Fuck it. In solchen Zeiten kann man ja einmal mal so eine Idee pitchen. Hau's raus! Wo ich meine, die Idee hatte, ist das eine Worst Bird Production oder ist das dann wieder? Das ist jetzt gerade noch, okay, lass mal eine Worst Bird Idea. Ja. Wo man, ich wollte immer so eine Mystery-Serie machen, so ein bisschen noch lustig, so Twin Peaks, halt ein bisschen mit Augenzwinkern lustig, wo so eine Familie nach Hassloch zieht und so ein kleines Mädchen, die kommt da an und die findet alles ganz cool, weil es ist ja auch eine Stadt, die gibt es ja wirklich, Hassloch, da lebt es die durchschnittlichste deutsche Stadt und deswegen werden da gerne mal Produkte getestet. Im Supermarkt gibt es zum Beispiel Chipsorten, die es noch nirgendwo anders gibt. Das könnt ihr mal gucken.
Vielleicht kommt ihr sogar aus Hassloch und habt immer coole Sachen in eurem Supermarkt stehen.
Und die Familie kommt da an und es werden dann so Tests gemacht an den Leuten, immer so Verbrauchertests und so und Umfragen und so was. Und nach und nach, dann wird so Stranger Things mässig, dachte jemand, dann lernt die halt so andere Leute kennen und die gehen dann so die Sachen auf der Spur, weil die auch komische Sachen bemerken, auch in der Schule und so weiter, passieren manchmal komische Dinge und dann finden die raus, dass nicht nur neue Chipsmarken im Supermarkt stehen, sondern auch so Roboter an Leuten getestet werden und der Hund von der Nachbarin, wo er gar kein echter Hund ist, sondern sich nachts abschaltet und eigentlich so ein Haushalts, so ein Roboter ist, der getestet will gerade, ob Menschen den akzeptieren. Oder so Touring-Tests oder der Nachbar ist ein Roboter oder sowas und die bemerken dann, dass er sich nachts aufschaltet. Fände ich ganz lustig, habe ich mal pitchen wollen und so, ist niemals geworden. Ja, aber es ist eine coole Idee, aber ich glaube, das kann ja auch sein, ich dachte, das geht in eine andere Richtung, dass sie dann auf so eine Gruppe trifft, die aktiv versuchen, Sachen zu manipulieren, die dann eben im Supermarkt ganz viel die Safari-Barbecue-Sorte kaufen. Aber das finde ich ja gut, wenn sie mit ins ganze Land kommt. Ja, wenn sie vielleicht so einen dicken Freund hat, den sie kennenlernt, der halt vor allem diese eine Agenda betreibt, immer seine Lieblingssorten gross zu machen, indem er ganz viel davon kauft. Süss, süßer Charakter, finde ich gut. Der Dustin, was Sturna thinks ist. Und erst machen sie das und dann merken sie aber auch, dass neue ernste Sachen getestet werden, wie Medikamente oder neue Wahlverfahren. Genau. Und dann denken die, okay, wir haben hier einen riesigen Einfluss drauf und überzeugen den den Rest der Stadt oder so und können dann damit die Welt retten oder die Tat stürzen. Und eigentlich ist Hassloch, da werden grosse Tests an diesen Menschen durchgeführt und vielleicht beobachten die das im Schlaf, Schlaflabore, Medikamente, ganz furchtbare Sachen, ganz schreckliche Sachen und dann driftet es ab von so einer lustigen, leichten Serie in so Todernst. Aber Staffel 2 wird dann wieder mega lustig. Mega lustig. Da kommen dann so neue Bewohner in die Stadt, die irgendwie total weird sind, ganz viel Slapstick, irgendwie die rutschen aus. Fallen viel hin. Fallen viel hin, das ist auf jeden Fall lustig. Das fände ich lustig, machen wir vielleicht. Vielleicht ist es die erste Best Bird Production. Wer weiß, wer weiß, vielleicht auch die letzte, vielleicht auch die erste Best Bird Production. Mal gucken, wie die Verhandlungen noch laufen. Mal gucken, wie gut es wird, ja. Und dann, falls dann irgendwie so eine Konkurrenzfirma Best Bird kommt, so wie bei in der Nähe von der BTF gibt es ja auch die Good Times Production. War da nicht auch mal die Idee, dass man eine Bad Times Production macht als Konkurrenzprodukt und so Sendungen macht als Bad Times Production? Ja, finde ich ganz gut. Wie in der neuen Staffel Curb Your Enthusiasm, wo er Latte Larrys direkt neben Mocha Joes eröffnet, was ich auch nach wie vor sehr lustig finde. Also wenn vielleicht wird Best Bird geklaut und wird so eine Konkurrenz und dann ist wie Lucky Lumber Slevin direkt auf der anderen Strassenseite gegenüber. Genau, neben unserer Worst Bird-Filiale. Headquarters gibt es dann Best Bird.
Wo wir dann so Crab verkaufen oder irgendwie sowas. In zehn Jahren, wenn die Firmenideologie sich komplett gewandelt hat und wir so ein veganer Healthy Crab-Sachen sind. Crab-Crab. Crab, ja. Clip-Crab? Crab-Crab. Können wir denn mit Schmiedern zusammenarbeiten, dass wir so Clip-Crab machen? Clip-Crab. Ne, dass wir so Craps machen? Clip-Crab vielleicht auch, wo man die schlechtesten Videos von YouTube sich unterladen kann. Clip-Crab. Crab-Crab. Crab-Crab. Oder halt Crab-Crab, je nachdem, ob man dann Craps will oder Crab. Ihr merkt schon, es sprudelt im Headquarter. Mit Hochgeschwindigkeit gegen die Wand wird diese Gb her manövriert. Es ist schwierig. Es ist schwierig, wir müssen mal gucken, wo wir da bleiben. Aber ich glaube, ich glaube, dass jetzt im Internet sich gerade eine Menge tut und es sich auch viel verändert. Jetzt gerade meinst du? Ich glaube, da tut sich gerade echt viel. Jetzt wäre es versprechend. Es ist so Web 3.0, 6.0 glaube ich gerade sind ja ich weiß auch nicht wo wir gerade sind aber dass sich alle so connect wo sind die zwischenstände warum mal punkt null ja wo sind mal die punkt fünf weil ich gerade habe das Gefühl auch unsere welt so wir sind gerade nicht in einem neuen wir sind nicht im nächsten level also du sagst Bescheidenheit man sich nicht sagt ... Punkt eins, Punkt eins. Dass man nicht postkapitalistisch, sondern so halb nach. Postkapitalistisch Punkt eins, Punkt eins, Punkt zwei. Punkt fünf. Ja. Muss man das vernünftig nachrückvollziehen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir in Punkt zwei bereits angekommen sind, wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin. Ja, schwierig zu sagen. Gibt's Neuigkeiten zum Peter, Peter Goitze? Ja, ich glaube nicht. Doch nicht abgesagt, oder was? Nee, ich hab schon die ganze Zeit in Gern Himmel gestarrt und so. Ist euch eigentlich aufgefallen, dass der Mond am Tag mittlerweile der Held ist? Alter, was für ein Wichser. Mir ist ja echt aufgefallen, vor allem, ich sitze da an einem Schreibtisch und der Mond, also so ein Arten. Schnallt dir in das Gesicht? Es halt immer, nee, auch tagsüber, guckt der so halb über das Haus drüber. Schnallt er mit seinen grossen Mondaugen, als wäre es nix. Ja, ich habe so das Haus bei mir gegenüber und dann guckt der so halb über drüber und ich lege mich so, Mond, Mond, weg, hey, so weil wenn der so ganz oben wäre, okay, aber der guckt immer nur so, halt, der luk, der luk, Mond, ja, Luna, Luna, ja, Luna lukt, und wenn du wegguckst, dann ist er oben, dann ist er im Himmel, ja, der nervt mich, der hält, auch nachts ist er hell wie eine Sonne, am Tag denkt er, wer die Sonne, nachts denkt er gerade auch, wer die Sonne, Man erkennt halt keine Reg so. Die Sonne hält sich halt an die Regeln. Die sagt, Tag bin ich da, nachts. Ja, nachts ist sie nicht da. Und du kannst dich darauf verlassen. Der Mond ballert gerade. Du kannst dich darauf verlassen, dass die Sonne nachts nicht da ist. Aber wie gesagt, Beta-Geuze macht nix, gar nix. Harald Lesch sagt, da passiert in den nächsten. Woher weiss der das? Die Strahlen, die jetzt kommen von Beta-Geze sind fünfzig milliarden jahre alt das ist kosmos ist sein kosmos am ende des Tages der kennt das immer wenn es einer wissen muss aber das hat eine mail haben wir zum thema betagoyze das ist irgendwie so eine supernova die den neuen mond sein soll hat stefan behauptet ist falsch nein ja doch es wäre richtig gewesen und ich habe eine einzige mail dazu bekommen und da hat eine geschrieben, das ist jetzt aber Beta Goitze, die Supernova war schon vor Millionen Jahren, und die sieht man jetzt erst oder so. Habe ich nicht gecheckt, weil es auch egal ist, mich interessiert, gibt es einen neuen Mond, ja oder nein? Tietze sagt, Tietzes Kosmos sagt ja, aber die Fakten sagen nein. Hey, ich habe einen Fictional Kosmos und wenn der cooler ist, sorry, sorry. Du hast ein Verleumdungsproblem. Nein, das stimmt gar nicht. Ich verklag dich. Ich verklag dich. Wir können mich auf Basis von Peter Goetze verklagen. Klar, natürlich. Buchstabier mal Peter Goetze. Ja, okay, gut, das kriege ich. Aber wenn du behauptest, jetzt alle Eulen müssen sich umschauen, wenn es einen zweiten Mond gibt und müssen sich komplett, was weißt du mit den ganzen Eulenfarmern, die jetzt mit ihren Eulen alle nochmal sich mal überlegen müssen, wie es weitergeht, was sagst du denen denn?
Den würde ich sagen, jetzt doch nicht, oder was? Es ist doch generell mal einen anderen Beruf aus.
Du willst der gesamten Eulenbranche sagen, er soll sich einen neuen Beruf suchen. Das ist deine Ansage, oder was?
Aber wie sehen Euleneier aus? Kann man die? Haben jemand Euleneier gegessen? Du bist von einem Skandal, schlitterst du den nächsten. Jetzt stopfst du dir deinen dicken Bauch mit Euleneiern voll, oder was? Das ist jetzt der nächste Coup. Schmecken die denkbar, merkbar anders? Weiss ich, aber haben die alle das gleiche System, alle Vögel, dass sie so ein Eigelb haben? Oder hat einer so ein Ei blau oder irgendwie so ein Gelb außen und weiss innen, so fuck it. Oder macht das alle gleich. Kann man aus einem Straussenei nicht auch mal so ein schönes Rührei machen? Ja, das ist so richtig viel. Vor allem, du kannst ja aus dem Eigelb ein Rührei machen, das Ei weiss kannst du weghauen. So ein Straussenei, das Eigelb ist ja riesengroß. Eier sind echtes, Eier sind weird, aber auch ganz geil. Ja, ich habe gerade keine Küche, also ist mir gerade egal. Interessierst du dich nicht für Essen momentan? Ist kein Thema für dich gerade. Essen habe ich hinter mir gelassen, ich habe keine Küche gerade. Das ist gerade noch ein bisschen nervig, um ehrlich zu sein. Du bestellst viel? Ja, muss ich. Zwarze ich habe jetzt einen Grill, habe ich jetzt. Und das ist jetzt ganz toll. Also ich bin jetzt eingezogen mit einer neuen Wohnung, wohne jetzt komplett da. Und es ist noch ganz fantastisch. Ich lerne noch diese ganze Wohnung kennen, ich lerne noch die ganzen Geräusche kennen und so. Das ist noch gerade ganz fantastisch. Es ist ein bisschen hotelig gerade, oder? Bisschen wie ein Hotel. Ich schlafe auch ähnlich schlecht noch gerade beim Hotel. Man gewöhnt sich noch ein bisschen dran und so und bei jedem Knacken denkt man noch, was war das jetzt für ein Geräusch? Aber man lernt gerade so ein bisschen die Wohnung kennen. Ist ganz spannend. Ich habe so ein bisschen auch bei mir entdeckt, ich habe so eine eigene Form von Weddingknall und zwar habe ich immer bei mir mitten der Nacht, habe ich einmal pro Nacht, immer in der Phase, wenn ich einschlafe, habe ich einmal ganz laut das Geräusch, wenn jemand Klettverschluss aufmacht. So dieses und das ist aber nur ein einziges Mal und das ist ja das Problem, das macht dich ja wahnsinnig, weil wenn das jetzt irgendwie ständig so ein Tropfen der Hahn, dann kannst du dem ja nachgehen und wo ist es und dann ausmachen. Aber wenn es immer nur einmal ist und dann ist es wieder weg und ich habe keine Ahnung, was es ist. Was sehr lustig war, neulich nachts konnte ich nicht schlafen, weil draußen ein ganz merkwürdiges Geräusch war. Und zwar war es so ein Stille, dann wieder für Zimmel und Stille, dann wieder so ein Rattern.atatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatatat an der Wand zu horchen, nichts. Dann wieder. Und dann am nächsten, ich habe schon wieder ganz vergessen, am nächsten Morgen habe ich dann mit der Nachbarin gesprochen, es war nicht morgen, es war schon irgendwie nachmittags, habe schon wieder ganz vergessen, was gestern Nacht alles vorsichtig gegangen ist, vergisst man ja auch, man ist ja dann, wenn es Tag ist, hat man ja die Probleme der Nacht hinter sich gelassen, so ein bisschen. Genau. Und dann habe ich mit der Nachbarin gesprochen, die man lernt sich gerade kennen, man tauscht sich viel
aus, ah, was machst du beruflich?
Und plötzlich höre ich wieder dieses Geräusch.
Und ich stand draußen und wir
beide, sowohl die Nachbarin
als auch ich, drehen sich beide wütend
um zu diesem Geräusch
und sagen beide gleichzeitig
das war's!
Weil sie es auch die ganze Zeit gehört hat.
Konnte auch nicht schlafen wegen dieses Geräusches. Es war so eine scheiss Mühle, so eine Windmühle, so eine kleine, wie heissen diese, von Kindern, diese Drehdinger, diese bunten Windspiele, halt so schlecht aufgesteckt, dass es halt gegen diese Barrikade haut die ganze Zeit, wenn der Wind im richtigen Winkel steht. Ah ja. Und dann dreht sie sich so, dass es gegen diese Balustrade schlägt die ganze Zeit. Ja. Und dann haben wir beide so gesprochen, das machst du, und dann beide hören das Gespräch, hören das Geräusch, unterbrechen sofort das Gespräch, weil beide gesagt haben, fuck, ich konnte gestern nicht schlafen, da, ich auch nicht irgendeinem Scheiß dann haben wir beschlossen, es abzumachen. Das war ein schöner Kontakt, wo man sich so höflich und dann plötzlich kommt die reine Wut. Beide waren nicht wütend. Einfach existenzielle Wut raus. Und bei beiden kamen diese Flashbacks von dieser durchzechten Nacht. Aber jetzt hast du einfach so im Boden getreten, einfach so nochmal die komplette Rache ausgelassen. Ja, das ist nicht mehr existent, dieses Windspiel. Windspiel, auch wenn immer mal Spaß beiseite. Ja, auch so diese Glockenspiele oder so, immer wenn ich das sehe, dass jemand so auf. Warum ist da nicht der Nachbar schon lange gekommen und hat dieses Ding in Brand gesetzt, einfach zertrümmert? Wenn ich das Geräusch wahrnehme, bin ich schon auf meinen Füssen. Da habe ich schon die Schuhe angezogen. Wirklich so, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, einfach, man steht neben und sagt, nein, nein, oder muss man es auch, glaube ich, ja, aber ist doch, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich häng's, ich wollte es hier, nee, nee, aber guck mal, wenn da so ein bisschen Wind, dann, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, Ja, das darf man auch, glaube ich, entscheiden dann. Ich glaube, das ist gesetzlich. Ich glaube, es gibt bei Sachbeschädigung extra noch so ein Paragrafen, Windspiele und Dongspiele sind ausgeflasst. Diese Dreckswindspiele, auch in Caps geschrieben, wird sie im Gesetz des Textes. Hau so fest drauf, wie du kannst, Kollege, wirklich. Von mir hast du nur Rückenwind, sonst nichts. Du kriegst 50 Ocken oben drauf, wenn du willst, 50 kneten, 50 knete. Ja, Herr Doktor Schnibli, das können Sie so nicht in dieses Gesetzbuch schreiben. Klar, dieser scheiß Drecksteil, der kriegt da 50 Ocken auf die Faust. Herr Doktor Schnibli, das können Sie nicht so da reinschreiben. Nein, ich habe keinen Bock drauf. Wir müssen nicht nur mehr reinschreiben, was die Leute nicht dürfen, sondern auch, was sie machen sollen in diese Gesetzgebiete. Wir entlassen sie hiermit aus dem Gesetzbuch. Nein, es gibt ein Gesetz, das ihr mich nicht in das dürft, habe ich reingeschrieben. Wann? Gestern. Reingeschrieben, als sie geschlafen haben. Ihr mit eurem Schlaf, ihr Idioten. Man kriegt zu viel zustande, wenn man aufhört zu schlafen. Es ist ein langer Tag. Was machen Menschen, wenn es die
Notwendigkeit des Schlafes nicht mehr gibt?
Alter, ich glaube, das ist wirklich
der Albtraum. Schlaf ist die
beste Idee aller Zeiten.
Aber allein, was du gerade
gesagt hast, du liegst im Band und denkst, oh Gott, Probleme,
Zukunftsangst, Hilfe,
finanziellisch eingeschlafen, nächste Morgen
ein neuer Tag, los geht's. Und du hast
einfach alles vergessen. Stell dir vor,
du würdest diese Sorgen einfach direkt mit in den
nächsten Tag tragen, wie furchtbar das wäre.
Ja, oder
das ist das Normalste der Welt dann, weil du halt
nicht mehr schlafen musst.
Da würdest du dich vielleicht um deine Probleme kümmern, damit die weg sind.
Auch spannende Filmpremisse.
Leuten werden
so eine Sonde
in den Kopf gelegt. in den Kopf gelegt,
auf den Kopf gelegt,
dass man nicht mehr schlafen muss.
Und dann folgt man einem
der... Genau, aus
dessen Perspektive erzählt man diese Geschichte.
Schlaf, Professor.
Ich sag dir eine Filmpremisse, du sagst mir,
aus wessen Perspektive man diese
Geschichte erzählt. Okay. Okay?
Also, im Grand Canyon, wo der, nee, in, wie heißt er,
Rushmore, Mount Rushmore, mit den vier Gesichtern,
es stellt sich raus, es gibt auf der Rückseite noch ein fünftes Gesicht.
Das erzählen wir aus der Perspektive von dem Assistenten von Donald J. Trump, der dann auch will, dass sein Gesicht darauf gemacht wird. Ja. Oder Indiana Jones. Mein Name ist Donald J. Trump. Donald J. Trump.
Jeremy... Was ist J eigentlich?
Jeremy Trump? Joe. Jason? Donald Joe Trump? Justin. Donald Justin Trump. Beim beliebten russischen Brothersteller Balsen kam es im Jahre 1962 zu einem grossen Skandal, denn nicht nur wurden die bekannten leckeren russisch Brotplätzchen in allen 26 Buchstaben vertreten, sondern es hatte sich auch eine 26. Form reingeschlichen. Das Ö. Das Ö. Ö gibt es, glaube ich, oder? Wie? Da sind unten an der Packung ganz viele Umlaute, ganz viele Punkte. Das war ein Ö, das ich gegessen habe. War die runtergefallen. Ich dachte, es ist ein U. Da ist ein Krümel drin. Nein, es sind Punkte. Es sind nicht die I-Punkte. Es sind Punkte. Ja? Doch. Es gibt ja auch ein Fragezeichen. Und müsste russisch Brot nicht das kyrillische Alphabet haben? Ich glaube, das ist eine Geschichte. Putin verklagt Russisch Brot, dass es Kirill sein müsste. Aus wessen Perspektive erzählen wir diese Geschichte? Fredrik Bahlsen. Ist es der Erbe oder ist es der Mainman? Der Sohn, der dabei ist, die Firma zu übernehmen, die aber vor dem finanziellen Ruin steht, der jetzt überlegen muss, geht er dem Kreml nach oder gibt er dem nicht nach, dem finanziellen Druck. Der Kreml? Der Kreml, der Putin. Ich glaube, das heißt Kreml, oder? Kreml. Ich dachte Kreml. Aber man schreibt es doch K-R-E-M-L. Aber Kreml klingt wesentlich weniger bedrohlich. Nein, das klingt wie so ein Kreml. Ichung für Kinder. Mama, kann ich noch einen Creme haben? Ja, da. Sehr schön, sehr gut. Vielleicht ist das die erste Worst-Bird-Production.
Schöne, mit Creme gefüllte Plätzchen.
Creme Plätzchen.
Wir haben noch eine ganze Menge vor uns,
und auch ihr habt eine fantastische Woche vor euch.
Mit Sicherheit habt ihr das.
Wenn wir uns in der Woche wiedersehen, haut rein, bis dahin ganz viel Spaß.
Ganz viel Spaß, bleibt gesund, bleibt auf Abstand und wir heben.
Macht's gut, ciao.
Ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, ciao, Macht's gut, ciao! Zu beides, bei der Präschen.